That's John was very tenacious people.
They love molesting child's.
It's crazy.
It's like their favorite thing.
I mean when you can get so crazy because
when you consider the risk and being a
child molester,
speaking not even the damage you're
doing,
but the risk,
there is no worse life available to a
human.
That being a child molester and yet they
still do it,
which from you could only really
surmised that it must be really good,
but from their point of view,
it must be amazing for that.
That joke offensive.
Some people seem to think that it is.
What if victims are watching what a
victim's parents are watching?
It's such a sickening thing that happens
to people that I know comedians try to
push the limit and they sometimes take
risks and they don't work,
but I think with something like child
molestation,
it's just not funny and he's too clever.
Like he could come up with a thousand
dollars.
What are we really asking?
When we asked whether a joke or a tweet
or an image is offensive or not?
We're not asking really whether it's
someone was offended or we know.
We're asking if what was said was
morally right,
how could somebody determined that?
How do we know what a joke,
for example,
is morally and I feel there is no forum
that is acceptable for this ever.
I know some
that was molested at three years old,
three years old,
no nightclub.
Oh,
no place ever deserves to have
that person.
It
seems to think that it's the effect of
the joke that matters because child
molestation is such a sensitive subject
because the harm caused is so gruesome
and lasting because any light hearted
mention of it could in some way diminish
the suffering of victims or bring that
pain back.
Child molestation as a topic should be
wholly avoided in the realm of comedy.
Now,
that's certainly a persuasive argument.
Comedies,
purpose can't be to cause pain to
innocent victims,
but of course that wasn't the purpose of
Louis.
CK is joke in the first place.
It wasn't his intent.
It just comes down to one question.
Intent.
It's all about intent.
It's only about intent.
In that clip,
Ricky Gervais' argues the opposite of
effect being the moral judge of a joke,
and instead says that it's the comedians
intention that really matters in the
end,
clearly Louis Ck is intention in that
joke is to use comedy to get us to think
about society's attitude and treatment
of pedophilia,
perhaps see intimate,
that we revile this demographic to
blindly taking solace in our normalcy
when we know that the complexities of
sexuality means that the urge to
pedophilia is not something chosen never
does he forgive or validate the act.
He takes it for granted that child abuse
of any kind deserves the harshest scorn
and retribution.
This,
I think is the intent and for many the
effect of this joke,
a subtle indictment of our smug
righteousness and our fear of the law
lessness of sexuality in civilized
society.
Indeed jokes are uniquely designed to
deliver messages like this.
They sneak into consciousness past the
barriers that normally defend against
the ways of thinking that threaten our
comfort.
Now,
that's not to say that I totally agree
with Jervis,
that intention is all that matters.
Clearly it isn't.
We have to be aware of both the
intention and the unintended
consequences of what we say.
We all know that too often those in
privileged defined the boundaries of
morality without taking into account the
decidedly different experiences of those
who've been subjugated or marginalized
or worse.
These debates about political
correctness and comedy had been
happening more and more frequently as
the Internet has given voice to more and
more people.
I'm always amazed at how the arguments
devolved so quickly into two opposing
camps.
One side,
we'll raise a concern about a joke and
the other will come down hard defending
jokes at all costs,
lamenting the never ending encroachment
of Pc police and social justice warriors
on free speech.
Just want to use these words.
That's racist,
sexist.
That's prejudice.
What all this says to me is that
morality is messy.
It shifts and changes,
and people often say that something went
over the line,
but there are no lines in morality.
There's a no mans land,
a nebulous fringe of very,
very tough questions.
The way I see it,
great comedians are like,
detectives will take a look at luther or
any other detective movie or TV show,
and it's easy to see that as a society,
we're sympathetic to the idea of letting
detectives bend the rules for the
greater good.
This is because we understand that
justice,
like morality is abstract.
Detectives are trained to navigate the
swamps at the edges of justice and we
give them the leeway to do so.
My opinion is that our best comedians
should be given the same reasonable
leeway with morality.
I don't know how the culture determines
who's allowed to do this.
There are no easy answers for that.
I think when a comedian is inducted into
the professions highest ranks,
we just sort of know though I see how
unsatisfying and answers that is.
Other than that,
all we can do is look at the jokes.
They're intense,
they're effect,
and whether or not we're laughing,
but if we want our collective morality
to remain nuanced and progressive,
we have to let comedians near the things
we find uncomfortable or perhaps even
wrong.
Hey everybody,
thank you so much for watching.
I wanted to let you know that I am
producing the nerve writer full time,
so I'm devoting all my time and effort
into making the best possible stuff for
you.
Stuff that I think is,
I hope a cut above the torrent of
content that is being pushed out on the
Internet everyday.
So if you think that the nerd writer is
something that you're not seeing
anywhere else on line on Youtube,
um,
I want to ask you to please support the
channel by clicking here,
here and pledging to my patrion page as
little as a dollar.
Everything helps.
I should let you know that the nerd
writer is always going to be free.
So if you can't afford it,
I don't want you to pledge.
But if you have a little bit left to
spare,
it would be much appreciated.
So thank you so much.
And here are some more videos.